[Musique]
avec vos hélène frade bonjour hélène
bonjour pauline à la une de la presse
donc la polémique qui n'en finit plus
d'enfler sur la finale de la ligue des
champions entre liverpool et le real
madrid c'était samedi soir une finale
donc émaillée par les incidents aux
abords du stade de france à saint denis
face à la farce française les supporters
voient rouge rouge la couleur de
liverpool deux jours après la presse
britannique en effet ne décolère pas le
gratuit métro accuse l'uefa la
municipalité de saint denis la police
française et l'état dans son ensemble
d'avoir manqué à leur devoir de protéger
et juge incroyable la réponse de l'uefa
de la police et de la ministre des
sports française qui invoque une fraude
massive aux faux billets pour expliquer
ces incidents il est franchement
ridicule que quiconque travaillant pour
ces institutions puissent penser avoir
fait son travail correctement
une rage rouge l'édition sport du délit
un miroir qui demande aux autorités
françaises de ne pas blâmer les fans
britanniques pour le cas au parisien
cite la réaction d'un jeu robertson
d'après l'arrière gauche de liverpool
les policiers français aurait paniqué et
l'attitude de l'uefa serait une bombe je
le cite sans appel quelle réaction en
espagne les quotidiens espagnols pauline
préfère consacrer leurs une aux joies à
la joie des madrilènes rassemblés hier
place cibeles pour célébrer la victoire
du real et de ses joueurs madrid
couronne une nouvelle fois sa déesse
cybèle la jolie fille s'enthousiasme le
quotidien sportif marca ces images de
liesse n'efface pas pour autant les
heurts de samedi soir les incidents qui
ont précédé la finale de la ligue des
champions font honte à la france la
vanguardia le journal catalan cet état
de la réaction sans surprise de la
presse populaire britannique très
agressive on l'a entendu envers les
organisateurs français évoque lui la
gueule de bois des français après les
images malheureuse de leurs policiers
débordés réprimant les supporters de
liverpool à coup de gaz lacrymo de
matraques et de coups de pied d'après le
quotidien les excuses du ministre de
l'intérieur français gérald darmanin de
la préfecture de police et lui sur les
faux billets n'ont pas été convaincantes
et le paillis autres quotidiens
espagnols dénonce le fait que personne
n'assume la responsabilité des incidents
qui ont retardé la finale samedi soir il
ya eu un perdant honorable liverpool et
à notre vaincu pas si honorable à
l'extérieur du stade les instances
politiques et sportives responsable du
match en france la polémique prend une
tournure une tournure à la fois
judiciaires et politiques ne le préfet
de paris a décidé de saisir la justice
pour fraude massive aux faux billets et
didier lallement assistera vous l'avez
dit également à la réunion de crise
prévue ce matin pour cerner les
dysfonctionnements qui ont émaillé cette
forêt la presse française elle est
également très critique le parisien
aujourd'hui en france par le dingue
chaos inquiétant d'un raté majeur alors
que se profile le mondial de rugby de
2023 et les jeux olympiques de paris de
2024 la france parfois un peu vite
présenté comme championne d'europe de
l'organisation d'événements sportifs est
la risée du continent se désole le
journal qui est ce qu policiers
libération évoque la gestion chaotique
et violente du flux de spectateurs aux
abords du stade samedi soir et mediapart
lui emboîte le pas en dénonçant une
faillite des pouvoirs publics français
qui ponctuent selon lui de longues
années d'un maintien de l'ordre
répressif et inadapté souvent violents
habituellement le discours officiel se
méfier des amalgames et depuis samedi
soir on prend à croire quand chaque
anglais il ya hooligans qui sommeille le
figaro ironisé se demande s'il est
possible dans notre pays d'envisager une
grande fête populaire sans qu'elles ne
dégénèrent en affrontements pour le
journal les causes de ce qui s'est passé
samedi soir serait reconnu rebattu
ressasser l'immigration anarchique
source selon lui d'une dérive
délinquante habillé je cite de fierté
identitaire
24 heures en tout cas à pen helen après
les incidents à saint-denis d'autres
heurts ont éclaté c'était hier soir à
saint-etienne après la victoire de
l'agît de l' aj auxerre sur les verts à
présent tirs au but reléguant
saint-etienne en ligue 2
des centaines de supporters mécontents
sont entrés sur le terrain et ont lancé
des fumigènes en direction de la tribune
honneur et des joueurs la descente par k
o l'équipe rappelle que le club de
saint-etienne a été sanctionné plusieurs
fois cette saison par la commission de
discipline de la ligue de football
professionnel pour le comportement de
ses supporters un mot des législatives
du mois prochain en france dont la
campagne officielle commence aujourd'hui
lundi à moins de deux semaines du
premier tour l'opinion s'interroge sur
l'absence de dynamique du camp
présidentiel
le journal voit emmanuel macron sous la
menace d'une majorité ric rac et juge
les premiers pas du gouvernement
d'elisabeth bornes complètement éclipsé
par les accusations de viol contre l'un
de ses membres l'un des membres du
gouvernement damien abad et depuis ce
week-end donc par la polémique sur les
incidents qui ont éclaté samedi soir au
stade de france il y aura une réunion d
hier au ministère des sports aujourd'hui
à 11 heures à propos de ces incidents ne
se quittent pas là-dessus l histoire de
vous changer un peu les idées pauline je
vous invite à jeter un fils avait une
dépanneuse qui rapporte qu'un japonais a
dépensé la bagatelle de 2 millions de
yens soit près de 15000 euros pour
s'offrir un costume de chien cet achat
pour le moins insolite lui a permis de
réaliser son rêve le plus cher se
transformer en jolies boules de poils ce
déguisement ipa réalise pauline a été
fabriqué par un spécialiste
des costumes de cinéma et la nécessité
40 jours de travail sont heureux
propriétaires se trouve donc dans ce
costume personnellement j'aurais plutôt
opté pour la licorne
effectivement c'est bluffant elle aussi
figurez-vous elana tout à l'heure